I only got one word for you
just one word are you listening plastics
[Applause]
oh yeah cuz I'm sure referencing a movie
that's older than I am to an audience
that is almost all younger than I am
sure that's kind of go for like a lab
balloon hey everybody
latest episode of Doctor Who series 12
and that brings us to praxis
I'm really glad they said it in the
episode because I was getting paranoid
that it was gonna have weird
pronunciation that it wasn't gonna get
so this one let first let's be upfront
about something I have a feeling a lot
of people are gonna say that it feels
like a step back or a step down
following the previous episode fugitive
of the Judoon let's be honest virtually
any episode that did not immediately
pick up on those things that happen in
that episode was going to feel like that
that's not unique to Doctor Who you look
at the massive upheaval episodes of
nearly anything and the episode that
immediately follows it is usually kind
of bland I'm not sure if that's
necessarily by design but it does seem
to be the standard I think it's just
kind of operating on the principle of
well you know we just kind of you know
drove everyone nuts or blew their minds
or whatever would this last episode so
let's let's give everybody a chance to
calm down and like process for a bit and
let's not let's not strain them too hard
seems to be the general operating
principle of a lot of TV shows
especially sci-fi fantasy ask ones now I
used the word bland already and I'm not
sure that's the right word for this I
actually think this was decent it was
pretty good um like I said it's it's
going to feel a bit more slow and a bit
more casual certainly compared to
fugitive of the Judoon but certainly it
bears an immediate comparison to or from
55:4 doing much better the exact thing
that orphan 55 face-planted on so
friggin hard so before I even get to
that which I will but before I even get
there this you know what this episode
has that it has
really well it's got good atmosphere the
vibe and the tension around the doctor
and the companions in three different
locations just finding stuff that's
weird a little off and the pacing of the
way it's building the delighting for a
lot of especially in Hong Kong it's it's
got a good source of tension that is
building as it goes I thought that was
actually quite well done and maybe it's
just me I'm kind of I'm not gonna say
I'm super squeamish over anything this
sort of body horror esque but like
seeing the gay things creep up on
people's faces like that did that didn't
do good it's keyed to me a bit which was
good for what it was going for
you know unlucky coincidence that this
became oddly relevant in terms of
addressing uh worldwide pandemic god I
hope this thing doesn't end up that bad
but yeah obviously that wasn't planned
I'm pretty sure the BBC didn't cause the
coronavirus but that that is uh it is a
bit of odd timing as far as that goes
now the splitting up of the Companions
was it didn't bugged me as much as I
would have thought if you told me in
advance
oh they kind of split everybody up for a
bit I would have gone and actually kind
of worked a little bit here especially
with the as I feel like I'm finally
starting to get personality off of yes
for one thing she is pigheaded and
reckless like she goes back to this
place with aliens who were just shooting
at them to get a piece of equipment that
she doesn't know what it is or how it
works or if it'll help and then when
she's there sees one of them teleporting
and goes yeah let's do that
like there's a million reasons why that
was a bad idea I
the fact that that these a that these
aliens wore get or what for all she
knows our aliens they did turn out to be
but whatever are wearing gas masks like
there where your breathing apparatus in
your atmosphere that could very well
mean that in their own atmosphere you
can't breathe there but just there she
goes
now you can say that that makes her an
idiot or stupid or what have you
for my part I'm just going with reckless
and that is a that is a much stronger
sense of personality that I've gotten
from you as in this episode then I've
had in a while from her and that was
nice to see it's yeah it's just it's the
most I've gotten off her in a while I
feel like it's the first time they
really found much for her to do
not that she necessarily pivoted the
plot or anything of the episode as a
whole but like stuff happened that
brought out her personality a bit
finally and like there have been little
tiny hints at this like when she was in
in spy fall when she was pretending to
be in the reporter she was really kind
of needling um that guy who she was
interviewing who she knew was up to
something and in high Sam like those
kind of reckless she could have been way
more subtle but she didn't wanna so she
didn't like okay I'm starting to get a
sense of you now finally geez so that's
good the birds that was kind of
unsettling in a way that worked pretty
well for me uh now let's get to the
thing that I mentioned before which was
the idea that this does much better
what orphan 55 failed so badly at so the
instant the word microplastics was
brought up I I did kind of find myself
oh okay because whereas orphan 55 was a
bog-standard base under siege story
until about three-quarters of the way in
where suddenly we discover that it's
earth
and then at the very end have a lecture
from the doctor here Ron about halfway
in we get the drop on the plastics but
Plus this got planted in scene one with
those two women coming up on this on
this river the and is it's covered in
plastic trash so that whole idea of the
plastics being around is planted right
from the get-go
and then it gets introduced oh this is
part of the problem oh and then it's
worked into the issue and the solution
and the settings because they go to a
crash site underneath a massive
collection of plastic garbage in the
ocean it's actually worked into the
story as opposed to being a completely
pointless twist near the end that has no
meaning and then a lecture point at the
very end for everything about our
fifty-five that felt crowbarred in and
didn't flow naturally out of the story
this is actually integrating the message
into the narrative it's not that friggin
hard this episode does that I thank you
but overall as much as you know this has
a number of things that I like and
certainly compared to other things while
I'll praise it relative door from fifty
five I don't think it's a phenomenal
episode um I had the strong points I
like that I'm finally getting a better
sense of Yeahs I do like the sense of
atmosphere I do think there was a good
sense of building tension or even dread
to a certain degree so I'm happy to see
that and I'm diggin all that but
ultimately it just didn't leave a ton of
impact it just uh it just kind of flowed
well it's decent if this had been in
series of love and probably would have
been one of the better standalone
episodes which I mean they all were and
that but it's it's just solid and that's
about all that I've got to say
because there isn't enough going on to
like really get me worked up in any kind
of negative way or for me to like shower
with praise in a positive way it it
comes in does the job pretty confident
at it and it goes the supporting cast
was solid the main cast was solid I
don't think that the the astronaut and
his husband hit me emotionally as hard
as the show wanted it to but they also
didn't leave me completely cold and I
wasn't sitting there uh yeah the stupid
romantic nonsense which I'm liable to do
not because it was two guys just because
it was romance hmm but I didn't do that
so it must be it must have done
something right because it didn't bug me
even though I didn't totally hook into
it either but overall was just pretty
solid practice yeah for having to having
to be the follow-up act to fugitive of
the Judoon it doesn't embarrass itself
and it very easily could have
oh god imagine if orphan 55 and
practicies switched places and that one
had to follow fugitive of the June Oh Oh
what that would have been rough
practice what do you think about it it's
probably gonna be one of the shorter
reviews I've done for this series so far
but like it's just solid but what do you
think whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do as
well because there's the like the
subscribe commenting I mentioned I've
also got a patreon there is a link in
the description and there are in fact
rewards including access to a discord
and I have now started also making
certain videos available to patreon
supporters a little bit early versus
when they come out on YouTube so there's
stuff like that check it out
or don't you don't have to end of the
day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]